Japan's creative thinking has stalled in
recent years as its tech giants and
startups have struggled to find out why
I joined my friend noriaki Okubo back in
Tokyo for a chat about Japan's tech
scene over noodles
Aki is a well-connected tech guru
venture capitalist and champion noodle
slurper nor worked on my slurp tightly
after a week in Japan I had so many
questions for him how would you compare
the Japanese VC scene to say Silicon
Valley traditional VCS are really bad
because they don't want to take risks
there's a lot of newbie sees that are
doing pretty well new Internet companies
and you know they can take risk but not
the traditional you know salaryman type
VC yo manake says salaryman he's talking
about that image we have of the
conservative hard-working Japanese
businessman this culture rewards
conformity and safe business decisions
according to Aki it's a key factor in
the fall of Japan's tech dominance in
favor of the disruptive mentality of
Silicon Valley
the decisions that come up from that
kind of process is always gonna be you
know let's just do something that's okay
and nothing cool yeah what's that
company that does the robotic vacuum
cleaners oh yeah yeah so Panasonic or
Sony could have made that easily but
then in their meetings somebody would
say okay so what if this falls from the
stairway and there's a baby and it hits
the B even kills it let's not do this
it's too risky is there a big call it's
a change no way you're thinking I mean I
think there is but it's just still very
the minority yeah with a bit of luck
Japan's investors and tech giants will
heed Aki's call and start taking bigger
risks